are you anxious about election day
results well you're not alone and here
to help us
navigate those feelings is mental health
counselor lacey
alderson hi lacey happy election day
hello mercedes thank you so much for
having me on today hello
well now i gotta ask is election day
anxiety is that a real thing
or are we just making that up in our
heads you know it is
absolutely 100 a real thing 70
of americans on general in general have
been coming forward to say that they
have been experiencing some form of
anxiety
around this election it's very very much
so a real thing
now how can we prepare for tonight i
know we're going to be getting a lot of
information
it's going to be good for some people
it's going to be bad for some people
how do we prepare for it absolutely it's
going to be a long night the first thing
you really need to stay focused on is
that patience we really need to work on
our patients like you said
it's going to be a long one maybe late
tonight even tomorrow
so be prepared for the long haul today
don't expect those answers immediately
get
mentally prepared another thing we're
really going to want to focus on doing
is doubling down in terms of our stress
reducing habits
anything you may do that helps your
stress overall maybe get outside
go for a walk call a family friend go on
a picnic with your family watch the
sunset
things like that those are going to be
really beneficial today now
as far as looking forward after today
once we get our results and
and half of the country's going to be
happy half of the country is not going
to be happy what
what is the sign of hope that we can
look for i mean how do we move forward
from there
well our number one thing to move
forward with is exactly what you said we
need to be looking for those signs of
hope
and you know people it's their birthdays
today it just happens to fall in
election i mean the world is going to
continue to move forward babies are
being born
grab a puppy look for the look for the
sunsets and the rainbows along the way
but keep your eye on that prize of hope
and anything that brings you joy
thank you so much lacey you can catch
lacey alderson on her podcast just look
for the lacie alderson show wherever you
get your podcast thank you so much
jc